[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: reCAPTCHA Enterprise
helps protect your website
from fraudulent activity,
spam, and abuse.
reCAPTCHA Enterprise
helps protect your website
by stopping malicious actions,
such as fraudulent transactions
and false posts, while allowing
legitimate users to interact
with your website, and
without interruption.
reCAPTCHA has been
defending millions
of sites for almost a decade,
and the reCAPTCHA Enterprise
service builds on this
technology with capabilities
such as two-factor
authentication
and mobile support,
designed specifically
for enterprise
security concerns.
There are several threats
that can target your web
applications as a result of
malicious web automation.
Credential stuffing
is one of them,
and we'll take a look at
how reCAPTCHA Enterprise can
stop credential stuffing.
Credential stuffing is when
there are mass login attempts
used to verify the validity of
stolen user name and password
pairs.
If we go to the reCAPTCHA
Enterprise Admin
portal in Google
Cloud platform, we
are able to see the response
of a legitimate action
from a real user due to
a couple of key metrics.
Number of requests
is a simple count
of how many
assessments have been
made with a particular
reCAPTCHA key.
Every time the user hits
a page that the customer
has instrumented, the
count should go up by one.
These assessments are scored
and we give three color-coded
buckets to help visualize this--
low risk, medium
risk, high risk.
Score distribution
returns a score
based on interactions
with your websites,
with 1.0 being a likely good
interaction, and 0.0 being
a likely abusive action.
reCAPTCHA Enterprise
calculates this risk score
by using machine learning
models based on user behavior
patterns.
Top 10 actions is a view
of the number of requests,
but instead of
separated by date,
they're separated by action.
Actions are defined
by the user when
they instrument their site.
Particularly, to be able to
analyze this data separately
from other actions.
For example, you might
want to tell apart
the traffic from the home page
rather than the payment page.
Top 10 risky actions is when
actions are being sorted
by percentage of risky traffic.
Congratulations.
You successfully used
reCAPTCHA Enterprise
to help protect your business
from credential stuffing
and other web-based attacks.
Visit reCAPTCHA
Enterprise Google
Cloud to get started with
reCAPTCHA Enterprise.
[MUSIC PLAYING]